[Music]
thank you very much happy holidays
everybody
I hope you're yeah I hope you're eating
a lot and drinking a lot and smoking a
lot yeah I know you're not supposed to
smoke and it was bad for you but uh come
on the coolest thing you can do they
haven't come up with anything cooler I
don't care how many commercials you're
gonna show me about people talking
through new holes in their necks still
the coolest thing you can do I don't
think it's that cool yeah now I have to
smoke like this
all my shirts are turtlenecks
it's not that cool
but they have a prompt don't you get it
they have a prop they can get through
life life is awkward and uncomfortable
and they have a prop you're at a party
with a group of people you're gonna run
out of stuff to say it's gonna get
awkward where the smokers do I'm going
for smoke and they leave they get to
leave I can't leave I gotta sit there
and take it I can't be like I'm gonna go
stand on your lawn by myself for a
minute no you're you guys we could be
cool outside smoke and I'm inside
talking to people about their diet yeah
yeah the people who want to live forever
yeah what are you eating yeah I needing
kale you guys eating kale I hope you're
all eating kale everybody eating enough
kale I don't know what it is my
grandmother never saw it my mother never
made it it just showed up like a week
and a half ago but it's here now you
gotta eat it well how do I know what it
is because it tastes like mulch and you
feel like a koala bear when you're
chewing on
look I like eating healthy but I'm not
joining your club why is everything have
to be a team why does everything have to
be like oh you're one of those people I
know you oh you're a vegetarian you eat
at Whole Foods you drive a Prius oh you
eat meat you go to steak houses to have
a pickup truck it make love to your gun
yeah
no no I eat meat and I have sex with
vegans that's how I live that's my leg
not joining your team everyone wants you
to join them now are you go to CVS you
just want to go to CVS you get up there
you get finally gonna pay do you have
your CVS card no I don't have to see
that oh you don't have it don't you want
to join us don't you want to be part of
us don't you want to join us no I don't
want to join you I don't want to be a
part of your club I want to take this
ointment and go home and deal with this
I don't want to join you I don't want
something on my keychain I've got money
will you take money I'll pay you double
if you let me leave and go home right
everyone try so hard you check into the
hotel welcome back Tom
what do you mean welcome back you don't
know me that's why I'm here I come in
late at night I do weird stuff to your
towels and I leave in the morning
stop trying so hard we're not dating you
go out to eat Oh welcome you ever been
to one of these before you're eating at
an Outback Steakhouse before just say
yes just say yes lai they go away and
they get your drink my wife likes to say
no now we've never been in one of these
before here comes the show here comes a
show let me tell you how it works here
we do things a little differently yeah
yeah you think you've been eating your
whole life chewing and swallowing no
that's not how it works
you order your appetizers to bring out a
can and we shoot it right in your face
you're your main course Dan here's gonna
chew it spit it on your plate don't even
have to chew we're great they all their
own credit card now do you have your
chick-fil-a MasterCard do you have your
chick-fil-a MasterCard no no I don't
well I can save you 15% off your
purchase right now if you apply for a
chick-fil-a MasterCard I'm sure the 20
people behind you wouldn't mind you
filling out some paperwork and running a
credit check no I don't care about 15%
of eight dollars I want to take this
chicken sit in the parking lot eat it
quickly before my wife comes out of
Banana Republic and sees that I'm not
following doctor's orders but how you
gonna get your points if you don't have
a card how you gonna get your bonus
points don't you want status no I don't
want status you shouldn't want status
either don't fall for it you're not
special if you got more points doing
anything you're all the same raw awful
don't let him to go it's true flying
here okay we're gonna board your flight
we're gonna board your flight now not
everybody not everybody sit down you
animals hold on a minute there's some
special people among you who have status
we're gonna start off with our
diamond-encrusted golden premier access
super douchebag flying guy Club
the whole place hands up the whole place
stands up everyone's got status leading
with their ass out of my way this is one
guy in the back with a crooked leg in a
cane I have no status at all and he
walks funny so they board him first
anyway
[Applause]